hi I'm currently in South Korea which
means that I'm not in America anymore
for those of you who are geographically
challenged I am here to visit my friends
and family I don't have friends but I do
a family and I'm here to speak the
language enjoy the culture and record
some cool stuff while I'm here this is
an announcement video for why I haven't
posted any of the other crap that I've
recorded since I left I don't know why
the internet here is just as bad as not
having internet at all if not worse it
just makes me mad at the Internet this
video is uploaded just because I
recorded it on my phone and that I
probably took it to some kind of coffee
shop that it do they have coffee here I
asked the walls
thank you walls and a Dunkin Donuts so
we're gonna not go there and then we're
going to enjoy the culture I'm gonna
struggle to speak the language which is
gonna turn into me shouting at people
randomly through guttural grunts and
moans and then I'm going to be enjoying
some top-quality cuts so I'm gonna enjoy
time with my family so there's that look
forward to more videos coming soon just
as soon as I find the internet place
where it is okay see you soon hey I make
videos for a living